Soypill, you have to absolutely talk about this. You don't understand
if you don't talk about this you're going to [__]
die, okay? >> No, I'm going like I don't know this person's
history and maybe you can explain but anyone calling you a PDF
file this is not productive to the conversation. Is Is sniffing
sharpies affecting the conversation framing here? >> Okay.
All right, just checking. Double checking making sure, okay?
Pause. Okay. All right, okay. Let me read down my >> I
handled myself and think I kind of cut to the chase.
>> Dan, did you see this? What is this?
Who chops is debating a
Wait. Other way around. Soypill is debating. LET'S GO!
BUT BY THE WAY, I don't even know how How in the world could
anybody be upset about that conversation?
heard you had some criticisms of that live and learn episode.
That amazing you know, every episode's the best episode ever,
all right? And um throughout all of the the snarkening of it
all I think we got to learn something.
Right? Did you feel educated? >> What do you feel like
you learned?
>> No. Um I mean, I do think it was a very >> No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. AstroTurfing which
implies fake
changing the opinions of these creators. >> is No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no. AstroTurfing is you are propping up creators
who aren't winning in like the marketplace of ideas. And you
by the way could make an argument this is good. They're not winning
the marketplace of ideas. Their content is not breaking through.
So, you're going to give them money. You're going to give them
resources so that they can continue to make content and put more
of it out making your ideas more like take up more of that marketplace.
So, you are trying to make it look like a popular grassroots
movement rather than you are paying people to go out and promote
your stuff, right? You're actually present preventing them from
doing something they could think is ethical in disclosing that
they're being paid as a part of like a political operation. >> Uh
again, I don't trust necessarily the >> You don't trust
Wired. You don't trust Wired, their editorial staff and their
legal team. >> Not based on what I've just seen. No. I
I don't I don't necessarily think this is portrayed in in what
I would call a fair way. >> It's It's just fun to have
um It's fun to have like actual contentious conversations, and
most people uh for whatever reason are like scared to call into
my stream and argue. So, >> Look, man. How about this?
Let's get you to 4 million subscribers, and let's see what happens.
>> Let's Let's Let's put me in the middle of two giant
creators who hate each other. I love that. That's cool. Let's
That conversation was like good. It was good faith on both sides.
I maybe interrupted a little bit more than he interrupted me.
Like, forgive the narcissism, but I do actually I do actually
want to see
this this conversation going. >> I'm sure that like I was
going to want to talk to you about like primarily Jstark and
the shenanigans.
Um but like I think Steven has already told you about all of
them. So, it's like I like there's not much I can really add
to it outside of >> Well, to be fair, I I don't know how
much he scratched the surface on that. I don't know how much
of it's true. I I try to stay out of this stuff cuz I don't know.
Uh and it's not germane to what I'm trying to accomplish, but
like you know, I can only ever take your word on it, and this
person can tell me what they think do. And yeah, I I I'm not
Yeah, but tell me what you want to tell me. >> Did he do
all the crimes?
>> for you to trust me, okay? Like, just so you know, okay?
Um mainly because I think that like the more I try to like actually
talk about these kinds of things, the more I feel like I don't
>> Boot Shop's getting like flushed right now because Soy
Pill with that hat is resembling a child. Is that what's >> No,
it sound like he's narcissistic or
control freak or whatever over the space or something like that.
Um but yeah, like like they are like my primary content is actually
covering this specific group of maniac stalkers. Um and yeah,
it's it's it's been a wild ride. They hate me, okay? But like
yeah, it's been it's been a wild ride. >> Okay, cool. And
uh yeah, just a preface. Uh if if your primary content is covering
people who I already hate what they do, not necessarily because
of the stalking itself, but just like why, who cares? Um I'm
going to hate this conversation so much, but let's go. >> I
don't have I'll I'll be honest, okay? This is just me being honest,
okay? I don't have the most favorable opinion of you, okay?
uh I think I think you're a little bit too left-leaning. That's
it. I think I think you appeal to Hasan a little bit too much.
Because Hasan Yeah, part part of the reason behind that actually,
ironically enough, is because um Jace Stalk and the others and
the anti-fans would spread like disinformation and misinformation
on purpose, and then what would happen is that Hasan would unironically
go over Jace Stalk's tweets on stream on his stream. Like they
like he would use Jace Stalk's Jace Stalk tweets and, you know,
stuff from the anti-fans to >> What's What's the misinformation?
>> smear Destiny with. And this is something that I have
like covered before, and yeah, no, like like that kind of stuff
is just it it it goes all the way from the bottom to the top,
basically. So. >> Okay. I mean, this is if what you're
telling me is true, this is not something I would be like, "Oh,
good. This is fine. I'm cool with that." If that's why you thought
I was too left-leaning and running cover for lefties, like that's
unacceptable to me.
>> Yeah, I mean like I mean like I I have I have said to
my audience like I suspect like I'm wondering whether or not
you're like mask on or mask mask off lefty Um but I think that
I I think the conversation that you had with Destiny kind of
changed my mind a little bit more because
uh the one where he was like telling you about like the anti-fans
like going after him. Like this rabid group of like schizo stalkers,
essentially, right? Like like in a way that kind that kind of
sounds like insane and schizophrenic, right? Which is why like
it's so hard to like explain this to anybody because anybody
who is normal, like they'll look at you like you're crazy, right?
Um but yeah, I mean they exist, and I can't believe they exist
myself. So, um yeah, that's just me though. It's It's almost
like a um It's like a It's almost like a self-fulfilling thing,
right? Like if you go looking for danger under every bush, you're
going to be finding danger under like some bushes, and that's
the thing that you're going to be like looking at, right? >> Um
if that makes
>> Hold on. Let's re-examine that. >> thing, right?
Like if you go looking for danger under every bush, you're going
to be finding danger under like some bushes, and that's the thing
that you're you're to be like looking at, right?
>> Profound. Very Wow, that's so cool. That's so >> Like
for example, one thing that the antifans do that I don't really
like doing at all, like I don't do it at all, is the sneaking
into your DMs thing, okay? Like the sneaking into your DMs thing
is like really weird. I don't like it, so I personally don't
do it. >> You did You did add me. >> Did I? >> No.
What? What?
I mean, how else are you going to get a conversation other than
sneaking into DMs or something?
Wait, how do you talk to somebody at >> I do that. >> Yesterday
you added me. >> Well, yeah, but it's not Yeah, but it's
not about like Oh, yeah, by the way, you should watch out for
these guys. They're actually a bunch of pedos, right? Like I
>> Yeah, like for example, like that's what I would assume.
Yeah, because I'm just reading out my side of DMs, right? Like
I say like How would you like to come onto my stream to talk
about the conversation we're having? >> No, I got you.
I got you. I thought you just meant like DMing like out of nowhere.
Not Also, guys in chat, I don't know why I don't know this person's
history, and maybe you can explain, but anyone calling you PDF
file, this is not productive to the conversation. Please >> Yeah,
I mean like I Like again, I'm pretty controversial myself, right?
Like I have no qualms about Yeah, no. I have no qualms about
somebody like digging into like my history on their own free
time. Like Like a lot of my viewers have done that before, and
then afterwards they're like, "Oh yeah, I'm actually okay Okay
with you." But like Yeah, no, like you know, we're we're just
>> Automatically go on a list. The FBI needs to be tracking
these people. If somebody digs into her history, comes back,
"I'm cool with you." That person goes on the list immediately.
Holy >> Controversial people covering other controversial
people in this space, >> That person got to go on the list,
man. >> I can't wait. Let's do it.
>> I mean, as long as you don't mind like >> People
concern trolling in your DMs after this talk, or even during
this talk, going like, "You shouldn't talk to this person. You
shouldn't talk to this >> Well, let's let's hear it. What
do you
>> Okay, so like when I was watching the debate, I got
like really really frustrated. I began talking about like the
different things. So, one of the first things that I noticed
was Do you remember when J Skeptic was talking about pushing
the party line? Pushing the party line is not a line in the article
itself, right? Was it something that he came up with? Cuz I'm
pretty sure I remember not seeing that specific
>> Hold on.
party line.
It's literally specifically scoped to the conversation about
the subtitle about this subheader section. It's literally that
is what we were arguing about that this is the part of the the
part of the article that they take the most issue with. It's
literally the most consequential disagreement.
Awesome. Awesome. Awesome. By the way, Soy Pol didn't even have
to look for it. I was pretty sure it was in the subtitle or in
the subheader. I think it's subtitle. I said subheader before.
I think I was told it was not subheader, but the article. >> Oh
okay. All right. Okay, wonderful then. Wonderful then because
this is something that you probably already like realized this
like throughout the entire
But I realized that you know, the way that he uses these words
is like okay, well technically this is true. Technically this
word is true technically that word is true according to dictionary.com
or something right? But I feel like the definitions of words
is not like just relegated or delegated to the written definitions.
I feel like the definitions of words also relate to what people
evoke when they're thinking of like a specific word right? Like
feelings, thoughts >> I wonder where she picked this one
up >> images and ideas right? Like for example, this is
why this is why when you search up like what is a woman in the
dictionary, you're not going to get like a really really good
definition that encompasses everything.
>> The whole Wittgenstein arc from Destiny by the way.
The meaning is use thing. >> right? But when somebody says
oh yeah, that person is a woman >> read Wittgenstein. That's
on me. I think Common Good has but >> Not me. Like that
type of um what what I notice is that like the feelings
that they use that is a they weaponize the feelings that are
associated with certain words.
>> I do think well, I do think Food Drop's actually making
my point for me in that pushing the party line, being accused
of this, it feels a certain way to somebody who's like aligned
with Democrats and wants Democrats to win and doesn't want Democrats
criticized. Like it feels a certain way. >> Are you following
so far? >> Yeah, I'm not really sure where you're going
with this. Are you coming into this to criticize my conversation
with Just Stilk? Are you here to talk about things I missed in
that conversation that you would have rather me said? Are you
talking about my misinterpretation of the article? Like what
what is what where are we going with this? >> Uh yeah,
sure. I mean, I just kind of want to share my thoughts in in
the first place. Like like share my thoughts in the first place
about what I noticed about the conversation. And I think that
these are things that you could have like called him called him
out on rather than going around in circles and circling the drain,
essentially. >> Yeah. Yeah. So so like the first thing
is that like you could have um said And by the way, I don't blame
I I don't place any of this blame on you, um by the way, for
not like calling him out on any of this, just mainly because
like um you know, I don't like backseat debating either, where
it's like, well, you know, >> I think it's really uh how
J Soc said this is the definition of a word. I think that was
a debate tactic. That's a total debate tactic, I think. >> that.
He shouldn't have done that, right? Like everybody knows that
in the middle of a debate, like things operate a little differently.
Um but yeah, I guess that's the first thing. It's like um and
I'll come up with another example of it a little bit later. Oh,
wait. Hold on. Hold on. Oh, another a better example is this,
centrist, right? Do you do you remember the centrist discourse
that you had with uh J Soc? Yeah. Okay. So um
the way that centrist has been used, obviously has a negative
connotation. And obviously, when it comes to the word centrist
being used, it it it >> Why is Soy Pill talking to a Because
he is creating a content cornucopia for us,
>> Oh, boy. >> an example like like what what what
did I allow him to get away with? Or what what should I focus
more on? Like >> Yeah, I think I think I think maybe you
should have stopped with the centrist thing. Like for example,
when J Soc was conflating centrist as being like used by liberals
and centrist being used by people like Lauren, right? I think
that the debate should have stopped there, but I noticed that
you guys were going in circles around that period of time. >> Sure.
I mean, I agree with him in so far as like that's not the best
point to focus on. So even if it is germane to the conversation,
it's it's like, you know, how long are you going to spend on
this one specific point before it's like, okay, you clearly are
not going to accept that people might use centrist from a left-wing
perspective as a pejorative, so let's look at the broader narrative
of this article and why it's negative, right? >> Yeah.
Do you do you think do you think that him Do you think that him
like not
focusing on like what the broader article is trying to say is
like um
a sign of bad faith? >> I don't know, because I've talked
to so many people that I would otherwise respect about this,
and now I'm like, I don't know if you just genuinely are viewing
reality differently than me or you're being bad faith. And I
I you know, it's a com- >> No, we're arguing we're viewing
reality differently. That's the thing. We're We are literally
acknowledging we review we see reality differently. You see a
like critique of the DNC in general, and that to you seems like
a like a criticism you don't want to stomach.
And I understand why it seems that way, but that's why I tried
to draw the the comparisons. I was happy he brought something
back and he was like, "Well, Wired's audience is not like leftist
or something." And I'm like, "Yes. Yes, they're not leftist,
so she's not necessarily trying to sue or you. They're also probably
not like hardcore blue dog dems that are like blue no matter
who. They're probably just like regular people who like tech
news, right?" And so they're they're reading this and they're
taking it in. I don't think they they they think there are bad
aspects, for sure.
But I don't think the bad aspects are like labeling somebody
a centrist or anything else. And there are bad aspects
So yeah, I I do think we see reality differently and that's like
core to the argument. Combination of both for some of the people,
but like some people are just like, "I don't want to see They'll
jump between This article is right for framing this as negative
and also this article is negative, it's objective and like it's
kind of hard to pin them down on one of those things because
either they agree with it and it's good or they agree with it
and but it's also not saying this is bad. Like it's just kind
of describing reality. I I I I don't It's hard to really know
what is bad faith and what isn't bad faith. Also, chat is asking
I'm not trying to be disrespectful. Did you read the >> Uh
yeah, I did. Yeah. Like maybe not the sub Okay, the subtext about
like pushing the party lines, I maybe have missed that, but yeah,
I'll say that I read it once when the initial drama came out.
>> You missed You missed the title, the the subtitle of
the article? You You missed this? It By the way, it's not even
it's like
not even if you just missed this and it wasn't a major topic
of conversation every conversation that's ever happened about
this Chorus article. If it wasn't like always a topic, always
relevant, always like the number one point of contention.
Right? Remember what I argued with Relle? Which I think she reviewed,
by the way. When I argued with Relle, this was his number one
problem as well, was the subheading right here. So she just like
didn't internalize any of the actual disagreements that were
>> I I guess I guess it's just really hard for me to reconcile
because because you said that you don't know whether or not he
was like being bad faith there, but I I thought that it was pretty
clear that he he Uh okay, well, I'm I'm I'm I'm here to tell
you this right now that J Stalk, when he still had a bridge of
Steven, he bashed Hasan pretty regularly. Okay. Yeah, so I don't
think >> Okay, do you understand that you're talking about
the Taylor Lorenz article, like a piece of journalism?
Actually, this guy really disliked Hasan. This guy actually This
guy hated Hasan before.
Where's the lie? She got you? I I would say
Bro, it wasn't even hate. It wasn't ever hate. I thought parts
of Hasan were really funny. And I still think those same parts
of Hasan are really funny.
There was one thing. It was like There was an I I still struggle
with this. It's the the galaxy leader thing. That that clip,
I don't like that. I feel like that was actually harmful.
But, you know, it's in terms of it being all pointing the same
direction that this guy's evil, yeah, I've had a reset on that,
which I
like I sort of once you once you see the Israel thing, it like
kind of changes how you view a lot of the stuff. Like a lot of
a lot of coin flips go in a different direction once you're more
informed or know more about what Israel's been doing. So, that's
basically I stopped seeing him as evil. And I still find the
same things funny. I still laugh at him for the same things that
I used to. So, again, I see how it it in direction in directionality's
changed because I like don't do, you know, Hasan Stark streams.
So, I have to take your word on all of this then assuming I do.
>> No, no, I'm I'm telling you to check it out yourself.
I'm telling you to check it out yourself. >> I don't want
to I don't want to like ultimately I can engage with someone's
ideas. I don't want to like do these like character studies on
all these people and be like, all right, like sure, it it informs
me as to whether or not I'm going to have a productive >> Yeah,
then take my word. >> No, I am I'm taking your word for
the purpose of the conversation and maybe it's true, sure, but
okay, but then what? Like am I Who do I talk to and say like,
okay, like yeah, I can it it if I know, for example, in this
conversation, which not this conversation, but the conversation
we had with Lauren, like I think Taylor's being ultimately defensive
about this in a way that like she is not being as forthright
as I want her to be. Um it It matter that I think that she has
different beliefs because I can try to point those out, but it's
not going to change the words that we're changing. I can try
to point out to my audience and I can just say like, "Hey, look,
here's the receipts. This is why I think she's being bad faith."
That's fine to point >> Wait, that faith that you don't
think it's worth the time to find out >> it in real time,
yeah, sure. Um and like it's important to know like, "Okay, like
is this person lying to me when they say all this stuff?" Yeah,
that's not like it's not unhelpful. I'm saying like when I'm
in the middle of this conversation, it's like, "Okay, like if
I if I engage with this person again, I'm like, 'Hey, I don't
think you're telling the truth here.'" Like every single time
I do that, I have to now establish that prior or during the conversation
over and over and over again to make sure that it's >> Soy
feels got a such a base response to Did you hear Soy talking
about Soy feel having a his own will? Yeah, it's good.
I I think I think he was aware of like some of the comments I
made and maybe like like I didn't I just didn't like um how he
interacted with uh Destiny that one time when it was like basically
what Food Chops wanted Food Chops was going to try to have a
similar conversation. I just didn't like that it wasn't a lot
of like Like if you're going to have that conversation, you should
dig in. You know what I'm saying? And so he's here he's trying
to say like, "Well, I don't really even care to know the truth
of this. Like it's not relevant to me." Which again, I as long
as people say that, I'm like fine with it. As long as you don't
sort of like nod along and and sort of uh agree with somebody
who's saying super negative things about someone else when you
have no intention to look into then I'm fine with it. So, I I
do think at some point either through, you know, other people
who watch both of us or
I don't know, through mutuals. I'm not even sure how it happened,
but how somehow I think he became aware of like how what I was
annoyed about and I think he made it pretty clear that he was
like, "Oh, yeah, this seems like kind of Just in terms of not
even making a judgment, just like kind of fair to if I'm not
going to look into it, I probably shouldn't entertain that conversation
like somebody like totally slander someone else on my stream.
And so I think he felt a little bad about it. I think he mostly
corrected it. Um I'm I feel like mostly
mostly fine with the way stuff's going now cuz he's he's mostly
like been okay. He's he's sort of corrected. He hasn't over corrected.
He's not like, "Oh, I believe you now." or something. He's just
He's just kind of yeah, trying to make his own way. And also
just focus on politics. Like if I I when I talked to him last
night he was like, "Oh, you could talk to me about that Destiny
conversation if you wanted." The one I had with him. And I'm
like, "I don't want to. I literally don't care." Like I would
rather just talk about politics. That's what I'm here for. That's
what I'm here to show up to do. I DON'T CARE ABOUT THE DESTINY
I don't. In terms of having this conversation that I'm actually
interested in, that [__] is way in my rearview, man.
I'm not like I'm not just
I'm not I'm not going like, "So, I BUILD YOU HAVE TO ABSOLUTELY
TALK ABOUT THIS. You don't understand. If you don't talk about
this you're going to [__] die, okay?" No, I'm going
like, "So, I build By the way, this is what I noticed. This is
what I know about this." OH, NO. OH, NO. THAT'S SOME LISTEN,
I get I get that she's trying to be performative or whatever
and but that's bordering on that's bordering on the Andrew Wilson
conversation. She's She's starting to get there and you think
that she could just do that and have it disconnected from how
she feels? She can't. It's all So, I build get I'll get keep
They literally said they wanted to go over that and then they
were like, "Oh, I guess Destiny talked to you about it."
>> Okay. Okay. I'm not Okay, you realize that I'm trying
to have a casual talk, right? Like I'm not here to interrogate
you. I'm not trying to I'm not trying to I'm chilling. I'm I'm
super chill. I'm super calm. You know, really down to earth right
now. You know what I mean? But like all I'm trying to say is
you had this debate. I've noticed patterns. I know J Stolk way
better than you. Okay. You can choose to not trust me, but I'm
telling you that >> He's Dude, I'm sorry. Destiny raided
food shops.
I do wonder
Oh, man. it's sorry, I just I'm laughing. Oh, that's rough. That's
rough for you guys, man. I just don't know. >> That's tough,
man. >> Tell me tell me more.
>> Yes, I I all I'm trying to say is that he is fake and
gay. I took this from my chat, by the way. Somebody said, "Don't
debate Jidion soypill." No, he is fake and gay. I'm like, "Oh
wait, yeah, that's a good way to describe he's fake and gay."
Um but like he's fake and gay. >> Right, so like in our
conversation >> context of him being fake and gay. Yeah,
go ahead. >> Well, just like yeah. >> By the way,
this is the with just a minimum amount of I don't know how to
push back. Everything these people say totally falls apart and
it's so funny to watch, right? Like literally if you just go,
"Oh, could you show me where that happened? Could you show me
like this thing or that thing?" If you
It just all falls apart. >> What what in our conversation
would have changed with information that I didn't
>> Well, I mean ideally speaking, you would if you knew
the entire context you would have been like, "Well, Jidion, we
all know that you don't actually believe this. Like we all know
that like you actually are just trying to defend Taylor Lorenz
because she's in association with Hasan and because you hate
Destiny so much that you essentially go directly You're essentially
like the teenage edgy phase version of being whatever you are
in right now where you're like, "I'm not like my dad. I do everything
opposite that he is doing." >> So that is basically So
it wouldn't have advanced the conversation. I would have cut
it off before. >> Right. Right. >> What Taylor was
saying to me is like the only reason you or any of these people
really care about this is because you guys hate Hasan and you
know that I am associated with Hasan. And like I'm like, "Well,
no, Taylor, like you know me. I don't hate you personally and
I don't hate that you talk to Hasan. I >> This article
and the response from Corvus was actually very interesting in
a vacuum.
Like it was actually like great content that I was hyper invested
in. I knew everything. I had all the arguments in my head and
I never got to argue with anybody on it. So it felt good to argue
with soypill on it. Like it actually felt really good to have
an argument with somebody who disagreed on this. I didn't even
get into like a lot of the other stuff that went along with it.
Like yeah, Brian Tyler Cohen's response and which soypill kind
of just acknowledged was a little too far with the the illusions
to be like friends with Candace Owens and Tucker Carlson. >> like
this article specifically and the the consequences of it. And
you know, you can say this like oh, Jidion soypill is just like
a crazy talker who hates Destiny which could be true but to say
that this now is like makes everything he's saying just like
he's manufacturing
in an effort to push an agenda like that's what it sounds like
and that might be true but like >> No no no no. What I'm
saying is that there is an impasse
in your debate.
>> Food Chops, here's your script dummy. Jidion doesn't
actually care about anything. He is spite driven and only learned
about all of this on Wikipedia the night before to dunk on Destiny.
He is not a serious political actor. Yeah, that's like a way
better argument Canadian caller. You just came up with that with
that on the fly? Yeah, that's like infinitely better than what
she's attempted to do in the first
20 minutes of this conversation? Yeah, that's that's good. >> impasse
could have been resolved
sooner because it showed up as a pattern before in his previous
behavior. I'm not talking about discrediting his arguments by
saying no you're fat and you're stupid. You're not saying that
okay? You're you're not you're not going like oh you're fat and
stupid so therefore your argument doesn't matter anymore. I'm
saying that you guys went around in circles for hours okay? When
if you knew prior context it would have helped you okay? Do you
get the context? That's what I'm saying. >> Sorry, give
me context. I actually think we did a pretty good job of not
circling the drain. I actually think we did a really good job
of that. That was some crazy
>> It doesn't mean like oh cool like I can just disregard
if like in the conversation like I know you don't believe that.
Does that help? Does that move it forward? >> No way.
What the [__] is this person doing?
Is person ill?
>> Cool like I can just disregard if like in the conversation
like I know you don't believe that.
Does that help? Does that move it
>> You sniffing a marker? >> Yeah, I disagree. So
I >> I just I can't get over how awesome it is and how
appropriate it is. One that this is Destiny's like number one
guy and emissary but also that there's the DGG logo in the background.
I just love I love dude, this is this is just clip bait man.
This is like what you bro
Food Chops about to make a stop on the Majority Report okay?
Food Chops about to be a feature on the Majority Report from
this person trying to argue that all these people you know defending
Taylor Lorenz in in way is crazy. Can we can we make that happen?
And then you could just get this with the DGG plushy in the background,
the Destiny plushy. This is Destiny's number one guy. He goes
and hangs out on this stream. He just rated her. Okay? Let's
>> I think that one thing you could have nailed her more
on like Okay, this is not talking about you versus Jstark now.
Okay? Cuz I am talking about I am talking about like Taylor Lorenz
specifically now. Okay? What you could have done is that I feel
as though and you know, this isn't entirely relevant, whatever,
but you could have stopped her from dodging all the time from
the question of what does this look like to a reasonable person,
right? Like what does this look like to a reasonable >> But
she kept on deflecting. >> Yeah, but you know, she kept
on deflecting. And then I just said conversation and she's like,
"No." And it's like, "Okay. Now what?" >> Well, what is
Hold on. What is what look like to a reasonable person? I'm not
Dude, the article is saying negative things about a Democrat
aligned person. That's true.
But those those negative things are true. Those are true things.
And it's not just true in like in that like technically we could
talk about how, you know, certain things You can mislead people
with only facts, right? You could do that. I've watched Candace
Owens do it. But it's like it has a coherent storyline. It has
a coherent through line. The story is coherent. And I think there's
possibly less nefarious reasons for some of those rules.
But honest honest to god, you have to you have to correct the
story. When they reach out to you for comment, you have to say,
"Here's why we do this and that and that." And you can make it
better. But they didn't even attempt to, right? And I don't think
their narrative, how they lay it out, is unreasonable to see
it that way.
And they reach out to you for comment. You are the people with
private information that could help them correct. But you didn't
want to do that.
>> Well, tell me to explain. >> And he did. And I
disagreed with him. And I was like, "Okay, it looks like we're
at an impasse cuz you and >> Well, then say it's being
ridiculous. Then say now you're being >> I was like, "That's
ridiculous." But then what? Okay, now we What we've
I guess. >> The conversation over because because because
there's nothing more to talk about. Like once you establish that
the other person is not worthy of reasonable good faith discourse,
like this is why I say like, "Okay, well, >> unreasonable.
Oh my god. It's not He's not even arguing that I'm unreasonable.
We have like a principal disagreement on
Right? And we both identified that we have a principal dis- We
just have a disagreement on this. And we move forward. We were
like, "Oh, yeah, well, I don't think this is going to work, so
whatever, we'll move on to the next
That's what it was. You can By the way, two people can have fundamentally
different principles or disagree fundamentally on some
like basic idea or some premise. And both of them can be operating
well, often both of them are operating in good faith. I'm not
lying about anything. I'm just telling you what I think.
>> Well, like this is why it's important to determine whether
or not this person is being bad faith, right? Once you determine
this person is being bad >> By the way, what is the definition
of good faith? >> Okay, what point is there to engage in
good faith discourse with them anymore? At that point, you're
just, you know, having you're just >> So, she thinks basically
if you have a a bedrock disagreement with somebody, they're auto-
you should automatically label them as bad faith. And I would
say that that's probably fundamentally incompatible with liberalism,
no? The thing she argues for and says is her
that if you have a bedrock disagree with
that you want to cut them off. You want them out. You You don't
want them to have a voice anymore. That is like antithetical
to liberalism. The whole point of liberalism is you should have
people who you have fundamental principal disagreements with
and still be able to communicate with
Right? It's pretty clear that she doesn't believe that she doesn't
believe in that, right? >> You know what, maybe it's my
bad because I didn't ask this question from the very start. What
What were you looking for when you were debating J Stalk? I guess
I guess like what was the >> Same thing with you where
someone DM'd me and said, "You want to talk about this stuff
on stream?" I'm like, "Sure, I've tried to stream more often,
but >> Yeah, but your time is valuable, though, right?
Yeah, but your time is valuable, >> No, man, I just play
video games if I'm not streaming. No, man, I'm just playing video
games. Maybe I go to the gym. Once I'm back from the gym, I just
play video games and like off for 8 hours, so time's not really
that valuable, man. You You message me, I'll I'll get on stream
and talk. I'll I'll get on stream and talk.
>> Depends on what though. >> I'm just trying to
I'm trying to I'm trying to put myself on the map more, that's
what I'm saying. It's like, all right, let's let's do more frequent
streams. And sometimes these conversations are fun and productive,
and sometimes I'm like, "Dang, why did they do that?" >> Well,
well, I mean, like if your if your goal was just simply to like
farm content, you've done it. >> No, it's not about winning.
It's like does this person have something interesting to critique?
Or or like, for example, he said, "Hey, I think this was a better
way you could have run this episode of Livin' Learn in general."
And I was like, "Hey, I took that to heart. That is actually
a good thing to do. I've come into this kind of blind. I'm not
sure exactly how to organize everything or schedule things."
Um that was a good criticism. I'll take that to heart. And then,
you know, we spent >> I I did not get even begin to start
criticizing Livin' Learn.
But I think I'm going to DM the criticisms. I don't think I'm
going to do them all as like a public conversation again. I'll
probably just DM the the criticisms overall. >> a half
talking about the article in ways that I just super don't agree
with. And that's like, "Okay, cool. If this is your disagreement
with it, I feel more confident in my answer." So, it wasn't like
a total waste of time. Um I enjoyed the conversation just as
frustrating as it was. So. >> I feel like people like Taylor
Lorenz
is destroying American democracy.
>> I think she is evil.
>> Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I've Listen, we should hear
it out. We should hear it out. He loves being here. He's He's
having a great time. >> Obviously, I'm I'm I'm putting
some sprinkling of humor in it. Okay, are you >> A little
bit. >> Okay, you clearly are. Okay. The point is The point
is
The hat doesn't help, by the way. Okay, just so you know. Um
the point is
Let's just say your belief is that, okay, maybe she should be
welcome
in our space. That's fine. Okay? I'm just saying a little bit
of background I think >> What I was saying is that I was
talking about people that defend her, which was you. You said
like, "I If Taylor is going to help Democrats, cool. I think
ultimately she hurts Republicans, but is in like the camp of
lefties who are like, 'I hate the center Dems, and I'm going
to hurt them a lot, too, and this might hurt our electoral chances.'"
Or if I'm going to like call Joe Biden or this sort of thing.
Like, that I don't know what we know to what extent I'm like,
"Yeah, this person's pro-Democrat." But you're talking about
>> No, sorry, Phil. You don't understand. She's a pro-Hasan
tankie who wants to destroy liberal
>> her article here, which again is a very >> Which
like, for all the things you say about Taylor Lorenz, outside
of masking, I don't think she I think she's basically anti-authority,
right? Like, she probably wants the government to make everybody
mask, but outside of that one topic, I feel like she's just pretty
across the board anti-authority. Like, hey, you're trying to
like do crackdowns that infringe on people's privacy, I hate
that. You're trying to like as a big as a big fundraising entity,
you're trying to like astroturf this these opinions to make them
seem more popular, I don't like that. It's pretty obvious where
her like biases
And it's very interesting to find respect people I don't respect
very
>> Does bad faith even exist in your >> Yeah, of
course. >> realm? Like, can you even Okay, who has bad
faith? >> Um like, I was going to give an example. We almost
got on this, but like when I think about who I want to talk to,
and I know like Andrew Wilson's like, "Oh, debate me about this."
And I'm like, "Okay, I know this is going to be a 3-hour conversation
arguing about the definition of something. You will never admit
anything that is true. You will never push the conversation further.
It will just be a waste of my time. It'll be really boring and
annoying." Um if those conversations happen like and I know they're
going to happen, then I'm yeah. I I'd like, "Nope, no thanks.
That seems like a waste of my time." >> You called her
a liar in front of her to her face. Did I miss that? >> I
don't know if I used the word liar to her face. I definitely
said it in our phone call where she called me later cuz she was
mad about this. It's a subsequent conversation, but I'm like,
yeah, Taylor, like I think you're not being truthful here. So
Like, I very obviously >> HEARD ABOUT
SO, I FEEL got in trouble. By the way, I believe subsequent conversation.
Did he talk to anybody else about that or was it just me? Was
it just me or did he talk to anybody else about that? Subsequent
She was mad about the subsequent conversation that she watched.
Let's go. Let's go. >> I never heard about the so-called
phone call that you had with her like after the conversation
was over. >> on the podcast, so. >> Yeah, and I do
appreciate you doing that on the podcast, okay? >> Okay,
wait. Wait. So, what do you want me to do here? I'm confused.
When I'm saying on the podcast, Taylor, you and I both know you
hate Democrats. You've literally said this before. You hate Joe
Biden. You hate centrists. You use centrism as a pejorative.
Is this not incongruent with what you were describing this article
as objective? And And now you're like, "Well, you shouldn't have
used these words, but said the exact same thing and saying she's,
you know contradicting or deceiving. Like I
>> Should I have been more angry at her?
>> I mean this seems like a Don't get me wrong. I don't
I have no malice towards you, but like this is a very silly conversation.
I'm not angry at all you. I'm just like >> Should I I don't
care if it's a silly conversation. You should have been more
angry at her, okay? I'm saying Okay, but your No, I'm not questioning
your performance in in the live and learn Okay, like Okay, I
question I No, no, wait. No, I did question it. I don't know
what else is there to say. So you you and J Soc went around in
circles, okay? I am pointing out stuff from his pattern behavior
that indicates that he is bad faith. >> And you're like,
"Okay, I guess I'll take your word for it, but I don't know what
I could have done in the middle of the debate." And I say, "Well,
you could have pointed out that he is being bad faith, right?"
>> I'm like this is ridiculous. And I'm like what's the
ultimate difference and I'm like and you can look at this whole
article and say this isn't negative or astroturf is a neutral
term. And I And I say this is ridiculous. I don't know what to
say to you. If I just also said
>> Sorry, but they didn't use astroturf. She didn't use
astroturf. I use
Like Okay, listen. Soy pill has a negative connotation. But if
I write my article that you somebody
Like I'm still writing a descriptive behavior out that is very
very bad. There's only so many ways you can write about non-consensual
contact before it sounds bad. I If you could give me a positive
way to write about it, positive way to describe it without
like offending people, that would be great. But they were objectively
astroturfing. That's why I used the word. She didn't say astroturf.
I said astroturf.
That's the argument.
Oh my god. >> And you're bad faith, this would have changed
what? >> Well, it would have um ended the
>> Okay, I guess. Sure. And then then then we stop >> Okay,
is that a bad thing? Is that a bad thing? Okay,
here's the question. Here's the question I want to ask you. Here's
the question I want to ask you. Okay, do you think that if you
cut out 1 hour of circling around the topic in in that debate,
okay? So let's just say we we took out 1 hour in
We we took out 1 hour in the >> I wish he would say, like,
what did we circle on? Like, the one thing we were circling on
we kind of moved on from. And every time we hit bedrock, we moved
on to a different topic. I thought we we wove Didn't he say on
the way out, like, thank you for catching so many getting to
so many different things? I thought he said that.
Am I crazy? >> of that of that debate that it would have
like not taken away anything
>> I don't know. I don't know how many people watch that
and were like, well, my mind wasn't made up before but sure,
I guess. >> You you don't have any kind of like general
gist in your feeling gut feeling that oh yeah, if you took away
an hour in the middle of that by now that you >> Every
conversation I ever have I'm like I could have distilled this
into three bullet points and it would have been clearer and we
could have just responded over text. So, yes, and there are plenty
of conversations that feel like more of a time wasting than not.
Um so, yeah, yes, maybe. I I just don't know if it was like thank
>> Food Chops the horse head in this analogy? I would say
the horse head was like the the call that he got to come in and
go through like Destiny's whole spiel about the anti-fan menace.
That was more like the horse head. That was like the menacing
you you come in and we we're going to have a little
I don't know. This one is like
This is like some this is like some lieutenant who's like a total
[__] and doesn't understand the situation trying
to get involved in a bad way. And I say that, but then also Destiny
raided her for this conversation. So, I'm like actually sitting
here I don't really understand what's going on.
And the rate the rate is so funny cuz I've been I've been telling
people this for a while. It's like, yeah, he's going to start
building Food Chops back up again. The fact that like I'm making
hay out of this uh this Taylor Lorenz article, he's going to
start rating Food Chops again. Sure enough last night he goes
into stream for like an hour and a half or 2 hours. Tonight he
rates her. It's It's very clear. He needs this He needs this
Okay, this is this is
that he needs to go out and convince people not talk to J Soc.
But unfortunately, then she has to actually use her words. And
if any of these people do the minimal minimal amount of pushback
of like, could you show me like how that happened or why that
happened or oh, I didn't think that was that bad. Yeah, she just
falls apart.
He needs a he needs a stronger class, a better class to argue
in his behalf and I'm not sure he's got it. >> Bam, I established
bad faith and now we don't have to talk about this anymore. Like
if that was the >> some people some people enjoy going
around in circles. I'm trying to determine if you're the kind
of person who enjoys going around in circles because that's the
only way to explain this at this point. You you enjoy you enjoy
going around in circles, right?
>> Okay, well well that confuses me because your propeller
hat clearly goes around in a circle. >> Fair enough. This
is hypothesis on my >> Yeah, exactly. So
>> Is is Snippet Trappy is affecting the conversation framing
here? I I don't know if that was the >> sniffing I'm also
sniffing the palm of my hand. Oh, the palm of my hand smells
so good. Okay.
>> And by the way
Destiny's this is Destiny's best friend.
Dude, I don't even I always go back and rewatch. I don't think
I want to go back and rewatch.
I don't think I That is actually stomach-turning in a way I don't
even have to play up in any way. Dude.
I was about to say that Destiny and Dan Salt are best friends
and this is Destiny's other best friend. I'm just I'm just saying
with with Dan becoming a respected free press journalist, I feel
like he's got to stop hanging out in these circles. I think this
is a really embarrassing person to be network to professionally
and I say you know, me personally, if I were Dan, I would like
not want to be network to this person at all. I would I would
personally feel like I need to distance, but hey, that's just
me, man. That's just me. All right. So I don't think I can see
why Hutch is friends with this person.
>> Okay, um but I'm trying to think about what to say at
this point because like I think I I reached the >> But
you can you can look I I've gotten all sorts of documents on
people getting sent to me all the time. Why don't you make make
still document and be like, all right, here's here's your debate
rap. You say, no, this is what this guy is like. >> am
I am I still doing my
What do you think I should make some posts on r/destiny and make
like a long-ass like post that and get some up dudes epic epic
Reddit gold up dudes? You think that's something I should do?
>> I don't know. Sure. If If this you think of If you think
look Now a logical person would think
that Soy Pill is advocating A-logging and stalking me, but hey,
you know what? I think he's just saying if I saw the evidence,
maybe I could evaluate. Maybe that's what he said. >> People
like the Soy Pill go to the conversations unprepared. >> I
could never get away with this, okay? If I said this, this would
be the number one thing in the in the document he's asking for.
If I ever said something like that, that would be the number
one thing in there. >> They could have saved so much time
if they just knew X Y and Z. And if I'm going to send this to
them ahead of time Cool. Do it. All right. >> Okay. Well,
well, this is just a post version of that. This is a conversation
version of that >> Oh, okay. Well, I'm Look. I guess I'm
condensing it into 10 bullet points. >> Oh my god. Oh my
god. Oh my god.
Okay. Oh my god. Okay. So, I'm going to Okay. So, >> As
you will see in a moment >> Just so that people know I
did actually write this down, okay? Because Oh my god. I I
Yes. Okay. I do have bullet points, okay? Cuz I'll do it, okay?
All right. I'm coming at your face. Oh my god. >> No, I
know I found it. I found it. I found it. >> Why is your
fridge door facing the wall so you can't open it? >> Sorry.
Fridge fridge door. >> Or is that a dresser? Excuse me.
I thought it was a fridge and I thought the door was facing the
wall, but never mind. I'm looking at it wrong. Never mind. Early
in the comment. >> You sure that propeller hat is meant
to be ironic?
>> Okay. All right. Just checking. Double checking. Making
sure, okay? Pause. Okay. All right. Okay. Let me read down >> Oh,
hold on. Hold on. We're fine. We're
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. OKAY.
Very cool.
This is This DGG This is DGG's guy. This is DGG's number one
Uh well, I'm using guy
in a non-gendered way, but for the sake of it Yeah, I'm going
to I'm going to keep saying guy. Number one guy. This is
This is crazy.
No, cool. Number one Number one person. I just
This is so This is so cool.
This is so cool. I just I Like,
I feel like
from the very beginning if Destiny had just gone back to politics
and like subtly tried to with my channel, my channel would be
probably in trouble. Like, if he was just doxing people but doing
it silently
If he hadn't done it with his own name and then befriended this
person, like, he made so many mistakes. I just sit here and think
I just count my lucky stars that he up so badly tying himself
to these total spastics.
My god. I could have I could have been into trouble, man. Could
have been a real big problem.
This so awesome. I just Thank you. Thank you, Destiny. Thank
you, Dan. Thank you for associating with this person. W these
guys. It would really be It would really be rough if you guys
didn't make it this >> Let me read down my bullet points,
okay? Okay. Okay. So,
takeaways. Number one, defining pushing the party line, negative
connotation. Definitions aren't just about strict boundaries
or not, but rather about the feelings and images and ideas a
certain word evokes. We went over that. Number two, you are able
to mislead and lie, and we weren't able to go over this just
yet. You are able to mislead and lie in a way even if you present
only accurate and correct facts. Spinning narratives out of correct
facts is tantamount for good propaganda, aka toxic
>> Yeah, so I point out how Candace Owens does this all
the time. You could totally do it. Just it being descriptively
true is not enough, but it's descriptively true and it's a coherent
narrative, right? If you can come up with a coherent narrative
that's all descriptively true and it makes sense and it like
fits in with a whole bunch of stuff going on, right? So basically
what Taylor Lorenz is saying is it seems like these people are
giving money and they want control in a way they've had control
before.
That's like the core narrative of what that article is saying,
right? I can see that they've been controlling before. I think
that this is affiliated with the DNC. They want control over
the messaging. I don't like that. I think all of that makes sense.
I think there is a more altruistic narrative that could also
make sense, but with no additional information, without comment
from the company itself, you can't even begin to tell that narrative.
There is no evidence of it. You have the contracts, you have
the word of the creators. This is the story that makes sense
with all the pieces that are there. Now, I'm willing to infer
this and I don't think Democrats are bad, so I'm willing to infer
this and well, I would even go as far to say as I think a lot
of Democrats are good. Right? I would actually go even further.
So I can see the other narrative, but I don't think it's I don't
think it's obvious on its face. I don't think you have to be
like a [__] to think otherwise and nobody from the
DNC when the DNC or when the when Chorus responded to this, they
did it so aggressively and in such a bad
in such a egregious,
not even looking to correct the story manner, just to like denigrate
this person and move on, that it's actually now very difficult
to tell the correct story. Like like basically I'm not sure if
the bad intentions were there, but the way they responded to
Taylor Lorenz makes it look like the bad intentions are there.
And so
for me it's like I can see the other narrative and I man
there's like two competing narratives that are descriptively
true. One is one is that hey, you want control over these people
or you want some level of control. You want to be able to pull
the plug on certain things, especially Chorus events and so you
make contracts where they can't identify themselves and you pay
them and then you have some control over course-related events,
and and some control over how they network.
There's another one that that all of that control is only meant
to be there even in a way that's like not even necessarily meant
to be enforced unless it has to be in order to comply with FEC
I think that seems more likely to me. But that one is not on
its face obviously true.
I think you could see why Taylor Lorenz is aware of some other
facts that lead her in a direction to think that this is more
about like the fact that they don't want to let this, you know,
unfold organically or they want to make their ideas seem more
organically popular. But I think that is totally reasonable.
I think that's a totally reasonable read on this. And if you
give no additional
man, you sure suck.
Yeah, the the points he made didn't really change it that much.
Yeah, I would agree. >> Taylor Lorenz, okay. Number three,
Jay Stahli conflates
centrists being used by liberals and centrists being used by
people like Lorenz as if they are one in the same. They are not.
These are the same word
>> didn't. I did never did that. >> they aren't in
usage and evocation. Number four, Taylor Lorenz prefaces the
the debate with Hutch with I'm very concerned about dark money.
They are unethical in many ways, paraphrase, okay? Which it is
a direct contradiction to any argument that Jay Stahli have made
about it being a neutral article, okay? By the way, the same
word, but technically they aren't in usage and evocation. >> I
I missed whatever that point was. I catch that. >> the
the debate with Hutch with I'm very concerned about dark money.
They are unethical in many ways, paraphrase, okay? Which it is
a direct contradiction to any argument that Jay Stahli have made
about it being
a neutral article, okay? By the way, just by the way.
>> I literally said it's not a neutral article. I said
it was descriptively true, and the reason you think it's bad
is because you think showing bad things that Democrats have done
is bad.
That's what you think. But it like obviously there are negative
concepts to it. I don't think the concept is Democrats always
evil. The concept is Democrats doing something evil right now
by trying to control these people and and giving the money to
AstroTurf the the more centrist lane.
That's it. >> Yeah, I I recognize all these, yeah. >> Number
five.
Okay, so there is something to improve on, see? You got there.
>> Wait, what do you mean? Oh, did I not say most of this?
>> No, no, no, like because Taylor Lorenz already prefaced
there's like a solid piece of evidence already where Taylor Lorenz
said, "I'm very concerned about dark money. They're unethical
in many ways." before she started the debate with Hoj, and that
could have been something you pointed out to J Stolk. >> I
can't imagine thinking I'm saying that the article is like neutral.
I said that Centrists was used neutrally, and I do think it was.
I have also said there was another thing that was neutral.
But like cons- like aspects of the article are neutral.
>> I So, I think J Stolk talking about the dark money stuff,
he was separating it from the complaints of uh Chorus and what
Chorus did wrong. And he's saying the Chorus stuff is just objectively
true. The dark money is like the main purpose of the article.
>> You think You think that the You think that the dark
money conversation is separate from the Chorus conversation in
J Stolk and Taylor Lorenz? >> kind of getting at and what
Taylor was trying to get at and whether or not it's bad faith
or not. I think it's ridiculous, but I mean >> I said it's
the core of the article. That's the core part of the article
is the lack of disclosures the core part of the article. And
by the way, where she shows her biases or in her post like post-interview
or sorry, post-article interviews, and I believe that's what
she leads with is it's mostly about the the lack of disclosure.
>> Okay, you should tell him he's full of [__]
because anybody is linking these two together, right?
>> WhitePill's chat during the J Stolk and this combo has
made me think about Destiny in a new way.
Funny how that happens. >> Like in that article.
>> Hm? No, yeah, of course they are. No, I'm not saying
this isn't my opinion. >> I don't She has the opinion.
It is clearly absurd, right? >> Yes. And I'm like, this
is absurd. This is clearly not >> it's absurd.
>> I mean, maybe I didn't use the adjective absurd, but
I was pretty obviously pointing out this doesn't make any
what's wrong with what I said about Taylor Lorenz saying I'm
very concerned about dark money, they're unethical in many ways
>> Oh, I'm saying I pointed this out and there was a deflection
there. So, like pointing this out wasn't the kill shot of like,
oh, if I had just done this, everything would have been better
and saved me an hour, right? >> I really really don't think
that like maybe I'm misunderstanding part of the conversation.
I actually don't I don't even know, but my my argument was never
something along the lines of actually this article is just broadly
neutral.
I'm saying it could be received a certain way. I don't think
it's painting Democrats as evil
is what I was saying. Is I don't think I don't think Taylor Lorenz
even thinks that Democrats are evil. I think she broadly aligns
with Democrats. Like 90% she aligns with Democrats. Which by
the way, Soyboy agrees with because the last time he talked to
Destiny and they were talking about the coalition stuff. Soyboy
argued with Destiny that Sam Seder is like 90% in agreement with
you.
You think Taylor Lorenz is like further left than Sam Seder?
I don't think so. I think that's like just like obvious on its
face. Very obvious on its face. So, when he says, oh, this is
like
he says this is oh, this is absurd and he's arguing that like
Taylor Lorenz used this article to kind of smear Democrats. I
don't think that's what she was trying to do.
Well, beyond Sorry, beyond what like was deserved. Obviously,
there are very negative things happening here. Some level of
criticism, some level of concern is warranted.
And I don't think it's like being massively built up into something
it's
>> Well, I mean like you I mean, I'm just saying this is
like going directly to the impasse, right? Like instead of like
going around in circles, which you say you didn't enjoy, okay?
Um instead of going around in circles trying to get to the impasse,
you can just like speed run to the impasse, right?
>> I guess. I mean, I tried to do this. I understand your
frustration as like someone who does watch debates. Um sometimes
you can, sometimes you can't cut to the chase. Sometimes it's
like, "No, you're dodging this. Let me finish my point."
but it is backseat debating and you
>> my best and I take your criticism to >> Okay,
you realize the only reason I'm doing this like backseat debating
right now is because you were like, "Okay, well, what is the
problem? What is something I can improve on? What is something
I could look like look upon this conversation?" So, just for
the record, you were the one asking for that, okay? Not me. I
came in here going like, "Oh, I think we should have a casual
conversation. It's going to be nice. It's going to be friendly.
It's going to be great discussion." But you're all going like,
"I don't know what I'm taking from this. I'm not learning anything.
Is there like >> A dude, Destiny's emissaries are Destiny's
emissaries down central.
Destiny said how he's number one persuader and they're
Dude, it's so crazy.
Like she By the way, this is like self-defeating. This This whole
conversation is self-defeating. Her whole purpose in coming in
here was like, "I'm going to tell you how you should conduct
conversations." And then she proves that she's incapable of having
a realistic professional conversation repeatedly.
Right? I might just catch the Rile Replay guy and all of his
life. That's fine. Well, I mean, you should stay. You should
You should Listen, keep watching, okay? Keep watching. But I
understand. Yeah, it is a little painful live, isn't It's kind
of rough, man. It's kind of
I just laugh so much it like internally. It's just so funny to
see it this happen and like
it's all I just can't imagine shooting yourself in the foot repeatedly.
Just as Destiny like by associating with Food Shops and trying
to get her to go do these things. I think I just think it's
it's so dumb.
I can't make sense of it. Anyway, let me >> anything that
you will ever do to actually evoke any kind of intelligent thought
or anything like that? What am I supposed to say here? Obviously,
so obviously if you're to say like, "Oh my god, this is a silly
conversation." YEAH, OF COURSE. OF COURSE I'M GOING to be like
going like, "Okay, well, now I'm going to have to start backseat
debating." Because if I'm going to because you push me to the
edge, okay? Miles Morales type [__] okay? Like there's
not What am I able to do? There's nothing I'm able to do, okay?
I'm trying I'm honestly trying with you here, Soy Boy. >> Sorry,
this is on my end. Like my stream it doesn't cut out for but
>> I'm trying with you here, what? Okay? Like there's not
What am I able to do? There's nothing I'm able to do, okay? I'm
trying I'm honestly trying with you here, Soy Boy. >> Sorry,
this is on my end. Like
>> Po- political?
I feel like she ended on poll so for pill. >> My stream
it doesn't cut out for it but
>> Wait, give me a second. >> Dude, the entire conversation
by the way, all of Soy Boy's language is like he wants to be
anywhere else with his life right now. Like he is just like he's
so detached, he's so weirded out the entire conversation. He's
just He's had this language like the entire time. >> Obviously,
so obviously if you're to say like, "Oh my god, this is a silly
conversation." YEAH, OF COURSE. OF COURSE I'm going to be like
going like, "Okay, well, now I'm going to have to start backseat
debating." Because if I'm going to because you push me to the
edge, okay? Miles Morales type [__] okay? Like there's
not What am I able to
DUDE, HIS FACE IS LIKE FROZEN. His face is just totally frozen.
I'm like, "Look at me move frames. I'm moving frames. Look at
her move." Look at his face
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE PIXEL THAT'S
I'M MOVING her all over the place. She picks her whole photo
up. NOT A SINGLE PIXEL CHANGES ON HIS SIDE.
HE'S FROZEN. HE'S FROZEN. He's not
She's moving all over the place. He's not moving. I'm going to
pull it back until he moves. Okay, he's blinking.
And she's like talking and he is just stuck. He's stuck. He's
stuck. He's stuck. Oh, there goes eyes. Then his eyes move.
Dude, that's insane. That's nuts. >> to do. There's nothing
I'm able to do. Okay, I'm trying. I'm not even trying with you
here. I apologize. >> No, no, no, I'm sorry. This is on
my end. Like my stream, it doesn't cut out for it, but
>> All right, give me a second. >> Dude, it's so
rough.
Sorry, this is a silly super chat. Thanks for a $10 though. Um
hold on. Uh thank you Gelatinous Rubes for the 500 kicks. Is
it racist to say Food Shop is doing a racist oriental accent?
No, in fact, if you missed I guess you missed it a little bit
earlier here. Uh I actually had the soundboard fired up for her
rolling the uh the L's and R's earlier, okay?
What did she say? I don't even remember what she said. Oh, hello.
I am Food Shop. That's openly yeah, openly sometimes. It's just
funny, okay? It's just an accent. It's just It's just funny,
okay? It's just funny. Come on. Okay, dude. Okay.
>> Okay, so let me summarize this and tell me if I've I've
done anything accurate. You have some criticisms of the way I
handled myself and think I could have cut to the chase.
>> I didn't see HER PULL THE MARKER OUT. I DIDN'T KNOW
SHE PULLED THE MARKER OUT. DUDE. This person is so sick. This
person is so
This person is I just I just keep driving home that like Destiny
rated this person before he went and did whatever he was doing.
Like Destiny actually rated this person. This is This is his
like favorite streamer that he goes and hangs out with. Dude.
Honestly, like at some point at some point like the weird
the the weird s- like degenerate pest vibe has to be enough to
start pushing some of these creators away, right? Like you can't
just keep hanging out with people like this and
try to do anything professional. Like it just It's just a bad
vibe. The whole vibe is
The whole vibe is just totally What did she do? She just sniffed
a marker. So, she's like She's like freaking out here. $14 >> Um
okay, dude. >> Watch her freak out.
And then she like takes deep breaths.
She's like okay, poke yourself in the face with the marker.
let me summarize this and tell me if >> I need to breathe.
I need to breathe.
Deep breath, deep breath. >> You have some criticisms of
the way I handled myself and think I could have cut the chase
>> And then rolls her eyes like this. Like this is just
there's there's a serious political actor or somebody who purports
to be serious. Like like to me, if I'm even IRI, I'm like dude,
I want nothing to do with anybody who's around this person.
Like I like by associating with this person, by associating the
destiny, the DGG, Digital Ground Game brand with this
like you are fundamentally disqualifying yourself from professional
opportunities, right? Like it's it's so
weird and gross to watch.
I Yeah. You got well, you got yeah, it's true. You got Dev over
there as well. Dev and Food Chops, big fans of Destiny.
I just listen, I I just really hope that free respected free
press journalist Dan Saltman decides to get his act together
and eject himself from the space cuz it's a little [__]
up. [__] up that he keeps hanging out with characters
like this or like, you know, he's got adjacent with these people.
I'm just saying, it's like a little weird. It's a little weird.
>> I have some criticisms of the way I handled myself
You have some criticisms of the way I handled myself and think
I could have cut to the chase better or pointed certain things
out. >> Dude, I just I think it's so funny that he's trying
to he's trying to like steel man and get like her criticisms
out so she doesn't feel like she's totally like thrown away,
thrown out with the just thrown away like your your opinion's
worthless. He's trying to not do that cuz he understands what'll
will if you if he does that, okay?
And this person's over here This is what I'm just saying what's
happening, by the way. I'm not like making this up. I don't have
to embellish. I just get to watch. I'm just watching and describing
the things happening on my screen. >> have cut to the chase
better or pointed certain things out that would have >> Oh,
she's going for another one? Another quick step. >> frustrating
to watch. Um there are some context that I might be missing on
this person that I could have brought up at some point and maybe
established them as bad faith, which would have saved a lot of
time because I can say I know you don't believe this and this
is how I know and I'm establishing this and whether or not you
agree is
is doesn't matter. The audience can see
>> Oh, like as he talks, he just keeps going back for more
of that marker. I just I can't I can't I I can't even pretend.
I can't even pretend. This is so weird, man. Dude, what is happening?
>> I I think that if you're serious about defeating the
Republicans, which I think this is something that she wants,
I think, maybe. Um if she is serious about that, then why
give us an equal disadvantage? Like that still doesn't make sense.
>> Yeah, I agree. That's why I don't like this article.
And that's why we talked about it. It was like, why are you shooting
Democrats in the foot when we're on the ropes against MAGA right
now? And they're doing something that you might even say >> Maybe
I forgot. How did she even >> She was like, I just care
about transparency and this makes us look bad. If we don't do
this, we win. In the same way Hasan can say, you know, I'm not
trying to shoot Democrats in the foot. I'm trying them to tell
them to be better on Gaza. And if they do that, then they'll
win, right? Like it's the same argument. >> but you know
but you know that's like concern trolling, right? >> Uh
yeah. >> Did you ever point out that they're >> You
probably at some point. Oh, no. No, you can't sniff your Sharpie
anymore. Yes, yes. Yeah, I think you're preaching to the choir
on like all of these
>> Maybe I just didn't say them all say them in the the
exact same conversation. >> no, but but that's my point,
okay? Like I hopefully you don't view this as like a hostile
thing, okay? Cuz this is just how I talk to people, all right?
Okay, thank god. Thank god. Okay, I I I talk like this to everyone,
okay? But like nice. Okay, so just so you know, okay, the only
reason is because someone pointed out that I'm being debate bro-y
right now. Like the only reason why I'm being debate bro-y
is because I'm looking for a contention.
>> Tomorrow I'm Pottery Politics $10. Tomorrow I'm confronting
Soy Pill on getting confronted about getting
Let's go.
>> Also, don't think it was confrontational. It was a fine
conversation. What the hell? >> Soy Pill thinks it's too
not
>> That's not Okay, I don't think it's not contentious.
I just wanted to know what the point of the conversation was.
And you you've established now to give me more context, to talk
about this again in better terms. >> which you gave us
an example. Oh, maybe there's some criticism or something you
want to push back on or something like that. So by your example,
this is what I'm going off from
reasonably speaking, right?
Cool. I mean, I'm happy you brought it to my attention. It's
the same way I can disagree with Just Old for 2 hours, he can
have >> That's so insanely disingenuous, by the way. Not
Listen, I'm trying to be nice to Soy Pill, but I'm happy you
brought it to my attention. Destiny literally brought this to
your attention and told you a whole other story. Like if when
you just say, "Oh, I'm happy you brought this to my attention."
Like you've had it brought to your attention. You don't care
to have it brought to your attention. So don't say, "Thank you
for bringing this to my attention." Well, unless you mean her
criticisms of on the debate or something. But in terms of me
and all of that, I
Or maybe he means he's happy that she brought her criticisms
to his attention, the same criticisms Destiny had, shockingly.
Just shocking Who would have >> I have 10 minutes about
criticizing the structure of Living in the Library like, "You
know what? That's good." That's in the Resident Evil trailer.
Didn't see that. Never played a Resident Evil game in my life.
>> That's a good point. >> I I don't know what happened
in that >> next time.
>> Taylor the Rentschler No, probably I'm probably not
going to just do that out of nowhere.
You can do that. >> Okay, okay, do you Okay, okay, just
one last thing, one last thing. Do you think that Is there really
nothing that could push you to call someone bad faith after a
debate like at some point in a debate like even if it's >> I
have already told you literally just called Andrew Wilson
bad faith in this conversation with you >> People I think
are bad faith and I I told you I think Taylor is being bad faith
when she's saying "No, my agenda here didn't matter at all and
that doesn't affect the framing." And we talked to the her about
that on the >> know about that take, man. I don't know
about that take, man. I don't know. Like I feel like I feel like
if you feel like someone is being bad faith, you should be able
to say that they're bad faith and provide reasoning and I don't
think it's a big deal. Like even if the conversation ends it
was destined to end, you know what I mean? >> You just
did that. It sometimes By the way, you can't call Taylor Lorenz
bad faith. Like let's say let's say Taylor Lorenz did a did a
I think she gave other responses. And I also think basically
what happens to normal people is something that's like outside
of the sphere of influences like consideration entirely. If you
confront a normal
a normal
30-year-old white woman, okay? You confront them. You go, "Why
did you do this? WHY DID YOU DO THIS? WHY DID YOU DO THIS?" THEY'LL
START throwing out a whole bunch of they they could have a good
defense and you could end up indicting them for murder with like
they're like, "Oh, I did I thought this and I thought this and
I thought Right? If you go hard enough on a person, you can actually
make them like kind of not give their best defenses first. You
know what I mean? They'll have like some reactive defense. Not
even just a middle-aged white woman, not even just a 30-year-old
white woman. Like I I say that cuz it's like I think of um I
think of like co-workers I've had when when they get pressed
by some engineer, right? And how they'll they'll not even give
like a good reason for why they did something. They'll like totally
shut
That's what I'm thinking of here is like an engineer going to
talk to somebody in marketing and they just sort of like start
they they literally just start saying things without thinking.
It's very funny. I don't know if Taylor was doing that. I'm not
even accusing her of doing that. But I do think like the real
answer should be "Well, it wasn't central to the article and
I I wasn't thinking about it. I just didn't Like, I'm sorry.
It sounds bad to say I'm a journalist, but I just Like, I wrote
it. I thought it was true, and I didn't
You should have just said that from the beginning, right? >> You
should have used the words bad faith
>> All right. Well, next time maybe I'll use the word bad
faith. I'll say, "Taylor, you're lying to me right now." And
I'll see how much better and less distressed that makes her.
>> Okay, but But, you understand Hold on. Can I provide
like a reasoning why you should use these specific words instead
of just like implying it? Okay, the reason why you should say
you're a liar or you're a bad faith person isn't because of oh,
epic soy jack moment. Oh my god, you really owned her type [__]
okay? It is important to establish this is what I strictly define
you as. This is how I view you as. I do not like you. I think
you are bad for this space. That is what it defines it as. When
you imply something, when you just insinuate something, it doesn't
draw specific lines for anybody who is like half listening and
playing a video game at the same time, okay? You need to be able
to say these words specifically because that stays in people's
memories for longer. >> Okay. Problem is I don't want to
write this person off completely because I do think they do good
work. I don't think they should be excised from the space of
journalism cuz if they're going to do, you know, potentially
good privacy coverage. And so, I can call
all them out when I think they've done awful things the same
way I would with anyone else whose political project I >> clown
show. It's just What a clown show. What a clown show.
And uh if I think they're more harmful than helpful for existing,
then that is when I'll be like, "All right. And this is why you
shouldn't exist in the space at all." So. Do you need me to stop
here? Give me the hand.
>> Okay. If >> Serious person trying to have a serious
>> And that is when I'll be like, "All right. And this
is why you shouldn't exist in the space at all." So. >> he's
just getting the hand, apparently. Do you need me to stop here?
Give me the
>> If If you think that they are doing more harm than good,
and that would warrant you calling them a specific name or something,
right?
Wouldn't that warrant a character analysis, something that you
said you were against?
>> Um if a character analysis allows me to look at their
body of work and inform me as to whether or not this is pushing
something they believe in or they're lying to me, it's not irrelevant.
I'm just saying I was trying to say earlier that like establishing
bad faith in a conversation is never going to move the conversation
forward in the way I want it to for most of the time. >> Okay,
look look, if you said from the very beginning
if you said from the very beginning that you don't want to do
anything aggressive >> I didn't say that. We can be aggressive,
that's fine, but it's just like >> Ay ay ay. >> What's
the best way to expose this? It's >> Because because because
because if you were truly valuing the bridge for networking purposes
that is a lot more understandable, okay? >> Okay, well
that's not the reason, but I do value the bridge for networking
purposes, but it's not like oh I'm not going to say what I really
think because >> This is such an inhuman conversation with
the pauses and stuff. It's like actually inhuman. There's like
no soul to the conversation, do you know what I mean? Like it's
a it is a soulless
dialogue. There's like like it's just the long pauses, the like
uncomfortable looks, the stimming, the the fanning your face
into Marker Sniff. It's like there's like something totally broken
>> Okay, it's fine it's fine it's okay it's okay. You don't
have to stop it's like okay. Like again, I hope you don't see
this as like me trying to be like like me doing debate bro debate
backseat debate. I hate debate backseat
>> You're literally not even making points. You're you're
like barely barely sentient in this conversation. The only thing
that was close to making a point is the things you wrote down
from Destiny's stream where he covered either me talking to this
guy or the Taylor Lorenz conversation. It's like the only the
The thing she's even getting close to making a point on. Maybe
that's why Destiny's friends with them. Is this is the one person
that sounds even dumber than he does on a
It's I like that's basically the best rational I've I've got
to come up with the past 48 hours. >> It is fascinating
because you want me to do it. >> Okay. No, I just thought
>> Because you want me to DO IT.
BUT YOU NEED TO POINT OUT THAT YOU'RE THE ONE THAT WANTS ME to
be more
>> Give me something >> productive in some aggressive
way. Like
All right. I'll I I hear you. Be better. I'll try to be better
food trucks. >> No, not I'm not I'm not I'm not trying
to be an insufferable woke scold and tell you to be better. I
just
I do. Why are you [__] with me? >> know. All
right, look. >> Thank you for bringing this to my attention.
Enjoy your Sharpies.
>> What? Do you like Wait, do you do you like Star Trek?
>> Yeah, love Star Trek. >> Oh my god, that's >> I
don't care about Star Trek, thank god. Thank god I don't give
a [__] about Star Trek. OH, THANK GOD. >> OKAY,
THERE'S ONE redeeming quality about you. Okay, thank god. >> Anything
say anything you guys want about Star Trek.
All right. >> Oh, she's not going to try to ruin Star Trek
for everybody. >> Which is the best series though?
>> Uh I like DS9 the most. >> Oh, all right. We don't
like these DS9 people in here, all right? This is a TNG
chat. All
uh I'm going to update you guys and then
Guys, thank you for the super chats. Uh No flame please says
no disrespect. This conversation is too online. Oh man, I I'm
super not doing a good job of avoiding drama slot, guys.